jean paul orillard desgeorges à grand
coup de grâce vous êtes tous les deux
codirecteurs de cette 32e édition de
l'open 86 révélateur de talents cette
année 32e édition difficile à mettre en
place avec cette période qu vide pouvez
vous nous dire ce qu'il en est
exactement là disons que le problème
c'est que nous avons été arrêtés à la
vraie 32e et d'édition qui était en mars
2020 trois jours avant le tournoi
donc on se voyait mal faire un tournoi
ne pas faire un tournoi en 2021
nous espérons balle édition 2021 on
espère bien sûr dans des conditions très
difficiles mais j'ai un très très bon
retour de tous les joueurs qui nous
remercient le le faire d'un ils sont
soulagés que nous le fassions
parce que quand même on sait que si nous
faisons pas ce tournoi nous privons des
professionnels de travail ce qui est
quand même pas normal alors que le sport
professionnel a droit d'exercer alors
c'est vrai que pour mettre en place ce
tournoi vous avez besoin de partenaires
nous savons cette année avec la période
qu'ovide les sponsors privés se font
beaucoup plus rares
nous en tant que département de la
vienne
nous sommes un partenaire historique de
cet open 86 qu'attendiez vous de ses
partenaires des collectivités que sont
je sais que vous avez également une
région nouvelle aquitaine grand poitiers
est donc principalement le département
de la vienne qu'on attend réellement des
collectivités savent ce qu'ils
continuent bien sûr à nous aider parce
que je pense que c'est ça donne une
bonne opinion de deux politiques qui
nous gouvernent dans notre région vous
dans le département ou dans notre ville
parce que en fait nous aidons des jeunes
et je crois à titre personnel moi je
préfère les voir sur des terrains de
sport que ce soit le nôtre où que ce
soit d'autre au sport je pense que c'est
primordial de défendre le sport donc
c'est ce qu'on attend des collectivités
nous ne sommes pas déçus en ce qui les
concerne les collectivités et notamment
le conseil départemental de la vienne
qui nourrit soutien et qui est notre
plus grand soutien
alors jacques en tant que co directeur
du tournoi mais aussi joueur dans le
tableau
je sais que vous allez jouer mercredi
après midi
vous avez certainement une belle vision
de l'ensemble justement des talents
tennistiques que nous avons dans cet
open pouvez-vous nous en parler alors le
premier talons ça va être le jeune
israélien qui sera aussi du côté sur le
numéro un c'est le laisse m haies dames
il est classé 391e mondial il a 20 ans
donc il est passé à nouveau un israélien
l'a donc c'est un jeune talent qu'on
verra très bientôt d'ici deux ans parmi
les options sans doute et après on a
failli en roumanie qui est ancien
vainqueur des petits as d'étape où tous
les professionnels dans l'option ils
sont tous obligés de passer par là et il
a gagné ce tournoi il est ici avec nous
cette année
quand vous venez de le démontrer nous
avons des joueurs des jeunes joueurs
internationaux il n'y a pas que des
français
pouvez vous nous dire quel air france
est classée qui va la partie du tableau
et puis à quel niveau se situe cet open
vis-à-vis de l'ensemble des tournois
internationaux
oui alors donc là comme français on n'a
rien romane qui sera le premier joueur
français comme je disais tout à l'heure
mais en ce qui concerne la place de
l'automne au niveau du tennis mondial
bat c'est ce type de tournoi en fait sur
leurs premiers pas pour premiers points
pour passer dans le creux au classement
atp
là on a vu ces dernières semaines on
avait un peu on était un peu embêté avec
jean polonia pour les invitations le
wave 4 parce qu'il y avait de crête ce
qui vous demander aussi si quelques
talents n'a pas pouvez participer non
mais t'es jeune de la négocie donc
heureusement qu'avec la fédération qu'on
arrive à très bien collaboré et on a
plus qu'assez
tous les joueurs que ce soit du creps
que ce soit de la libre uni ou de la
fédération donc il faut savoir qu'au
départ c'est tournois futures ont été
faits parce que en france on la
fédération à l'époque avait regardé et
trouvé qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'espagnols dans le dans l'est dans le
top 100 et il demandait pourquoi
et ce sont ces tournois qui permettent
d'acquérir les premiers points qui ont
permis à ces jeunes de grappiller des
points et se retrouvait devant toutes
les autres nations
donc c'est comme ça que nous en france
le tournoi qui était un tournoi
satellite au départ et ensuite qu'est
devenu tournois futures ce sont les
tournois les plus importants parce que
ça débute une carrière c'est à sachant
que financièrement c'est très dur pour
eux parce que souvent ils viennent ils
viennent d'en sur nos tournois airparc
parce qu'ils ont perdu en qualification
ils ont rien gagné
maintenant à partir de cette année mon
père au premier tour on a quand même un
peu d'argent
donc vous l'aurez compris tout l'intérêt
ce tournoi ici à poitiers dans le
département de la vienne tournoi doté de
15 mille dollars sans hébergement certes
mais tournoi très important pour nos
jeunes joueurs professionnels et puis
même si ce tournoi malheureusement se
joue à huis clos
vous aurez la possibilité de suivre les
différents résultats et différents
matchs sur le site du stade poitevin
tennis est également sur le site
facebook du département de la vienne